หมอ
ตรวจเลยค่ะครูเรียมสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิง
สวัสดีค่ะดีค่ะนักเรียนทุกคน
เพลงสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนก็วีดีโอนี้น้องก็
กลับมาเจอกับครูหญิงนะคะแล้วก็ครูเรียม
ที่ช่องคอมพีเห็นสิเบอร์ไทยนะคะ
วันนี้วีดีโอระดับวีดีโอระดับอะไรคะครู
เรียมวีดีโอประดับบีโฟ
B4  rbb  ct4 โอเคเราคุยกันวันนี้เป็น
วันอะไรคะครูฟ้าผู้หญิง
สีวันจันทร์วันจันทร์สุริยะ
ม.วอันจันทร์วันที่เท่าไหร่ค่ะ
วันที่ 14 ค่ะอ่ะเอ้อเขตเดือนอะไรคะ
เดือน
มีนาคมค่ะ
ข้อ 2 อะไรคะ
ปีคศ 2  0
2  0  2  2 ค่ะแล้วปีพตอะไรคะ
พศ.
2565 ค่ะ
ขี่แล้วตอนนี้ที่เราคุยกันกี่โมงแล้วคะ
กริ่ง
ตอนนี้หรอคะตอบ 15:00 น
12 นาทีค่ะครูเรียมไป 3 โมง 12 นาทีน
ชั้นเรียนมกินข้าวหรือยังคะ
เตรียมกินข้าวแล้วค่ะแล้วครูหญิงล่ะคะกิน
ข้าวหรือยังถึงก็ยินแล้วบ่ถิ่มแล้วค่ะครู
เรียม
คุณเรียมเนี่ย
กินแล้วแต่รู้อีกแล้วใช่ไหมคุย
ไม่อิ่มจะออกตอนนี้มันตอนนี้มันบ่ายสาม
แล้วไงก็คิวได้แต่ทุกๆวันเนี่ยครูเรียม
กินข้าวที่บ้าน
กินข้าวที่บ้านหรือว่าอันนี้ a นะกินข้าว
ที่บ้านนะบีกินข้าวข้างนอกบ้านอาจจะไป
ช็อปปิ้งเซ็นเตอร์
เดอะมอลล์เซ็นทรัล
กินข้าวในบ้านหรือว่ากินข้าวข้างนอกบ้าน
คะเตรียมกินข้าวนอกบ้าน
บ่อยข้างนอกบ้านเป็นอาจจะเป็นออกร้าน
อาหาร
ใช่ค่ะแล้วกูหญิงหรอคะกินข้าวที่บ้านหรือ
ว่าออกไปกินนอกบ้านขอ
เบอร์ผู้หญิงเนี่ยตอนนี้นะตอนนี้นะคะกิน
ข้าวที่บ้านแต่ว่าเมื่อก่อนเมื่อก่อน
เนี่ยเวลาที่ไปออฟฟิศไหมเพราะก็ก่อนไม่
ได้ work  from  home หน้าก่อนทำงานที่
ออฟฟิศ
หวยก็จะต้อง
9:00 นทำงานหรอกต้นถึง
น่าจะประมาณ
19:00 นตอนนั้น
19:00 นหนูผู้หญิงทำงานเสร็จคะเนี่ย
โอ้
ประมาณนะจริงๆทำงานแค่ 7 ชั่วโมงเพราะว่า
มีเบรคอ๋อคือเวลาสอนใช่ไหมคะเวลาสอนเนี่ย
ก็จะสอนภาษาไทย 1 ชั่วโมง 2 ชั่วโมงเบรค
กินข้าวคะแล้วก็สอนสอนแล้วก็เบรคแต่มันจะ
มีเวลาสอนภาษาไทยเวลาเบรคทั้งวัน
[เพลง]
ผู้หญิงก็เลยแต่ว่าเอาข้างนอก
เลิกงาน 19:00 นแล้วก็จากออฟฟิศกลับบ้าน
BTS เดิน
มอเตอร์ไซค์ก็เวลาใช้เวลาก็ประมาณ
1 ชั่วโมงหนึ่งชั่วโมง
จากออฟฟิศกลับบ้าน
หิวใช่ไหมหิว
ผู้หญิง 1 ชั่วโมงเรียมคิดว่าใช้เวลานาน
มากๆน้าๆว่าจากออฟฟิศแล้วก็มามา
คอนโดมิเนียมหรือบ้านเนี่ยนะคะ BTS โอเค
หรือว่า MRT ก็โอเคเพราะว่าออฟฟิศเนี่ย
ใกล้ๆเต็ม rt ไม่ใช่ MRT แบบมันจะมาลงไม่
รู้นักเรียนรู้จักหรือเปล่า MRT พหลโยธิน
พหลโยธินเนี่ยจะมีเซ็นทรัลลาดพร้าวให้
แล้วก็มีเจเจมอลล์
อมีเจเจมอลล์มี
อยู่
ยูเนี่ยนมอลล์ใช่จ่ายเป็นถนนอย่างนี้ใช่
ไหมคะหลายแยกนะลาดพร้าวเนี่ย
ใช่ก็ไม่รู้เหมือนกันเล็กแยกอะไรจะรู้
แล้วมันจะมี MRT แล้วตอนนี้ก็จะเป็น
เซ็นทรัลเซ็นทรัลลาดพร้าว
ใช่ก็จะมีร้านอาหารร้านอาหารมากๆ
มีหรอกอาหารญี่ปุ่นฟูจิฟูจิทสึชิซาชิมิ
อะไรอาหารญี่ปุ่นอาหารไทยอาหารฝรั่งมี
ร้านอาหารร้านอาหารร้านอาหารเยอะๆพี่น้อง
บางผู้หญิงชอบกิน
อาหารแบบไหนคะอาหารไทยอาหารญี่ปุ่นอาหาร
อิตาเลียน
ก็ฆ่าบางวันฉิวมากๆก็กินอาหารฝรั่งอาหาร
อิตาลีอาหารอเมริกาเพราะอาหารฝรั่งใหญ่
ใช่ไหม
แต่ถ้า
อยู่ทิศหน่อยก็จะอาหารญี่ปุ่นณวันนี้คุณ
เล็กๆกินเล็กๆได้ว่าเซ็นทรัลเนี่ย
เซ็นทรัล B ร้านอาหารเยอะมากๆใช่ค่ะแต่
ว่ามันมี 1 วันครูเรียนครูหญิงแดกก็กลับ
บ้านนะก็นั่ง MRT เนี่ยไปลงเซ็นทรัลแล้ว
ก็หิวก็เลยไปกินข้าวแต่ว่าบางร้านเนี่ยมี
QQ  QQ
ยาวก็ไม่หรอกอ่ะถ้าไม่ใช่ไหมผู้หญิงทำยัง
ไงคะอีกแล้วเดินหาโอ้วร้านนี้มีคิวไปเอา
นี่คิวไม่เอาไม่มีคิวมี 1 ล้านไม่มีคิว
ก็เลยโอเคกินแล้วก็เป็นบุฟเฟ่ต์ด้วย
เฟ
เป็นบุฟเฟ่กินสมัยร้านบุฟเฟ่ต์ในเขาก็จะ
มีสลัดนะคะมีสลัด
มีสเต็กให้มีสลัดมีสเต็กอ่ะก็กินอิ่มแล้ว
มันก็ไปกินนะเนาะกินกินกินกินสลัดกิน
สเต็กนะคะแล้วเขาก็มีขนม
มุกเดี๋ยวผู้หญิงมีรูปให้ดูค่ะเตรียมก็
แล้วคุยด้วยว่าผู้หญิงสั่งอะไรมาบ้างมี
สลัดที่หาญเทคสัตว์ใช่ไหมร้านสเต็กเนี่ย
เราสั่งไปชายๆสเต็กเนี่ยเราสั่งแล้วก็
โอเคเอาสเต็กหมูกะหมูอ่ะตอนที่เรารอ
สเต็กอ่ะเราก็เดินเดินไปแล้วก็มีจานไหม
เดินไปมีจาน
เป็นจานนะคะน้องจานเราก็ผักสลัดได้ตอนรอ
สเต็กว่าสเต็กแฮะต้องทำอะไรทำทำทำทำๆก็
กินกินๆกินสลัดในกินสเต็กเสร็จเขาก็มีขนม
ด้วยขนมขนมอะไรคะ
อ้าวคุยแชร์ได้ไหมเนี่ย
ได้ไหมคะอุ้ยแชร์ไฟล์ได้ไหมผู้หญิงลองดู
ฝรั่งค่ะเป็นขนมฝรั่งอ้าอะไรมันจะดีอันสี
น้ำตาลอ่ะนี้เป็นซ็อคโกแลตมูสนะแล้วก็มี
อันนี้เป็นอารี่มังค์เยลลี่สีแดงๆอีกแล้ว
ไม่ได้กินเยลลี่นะกินช็อกโกแลตมูสอะนี้
อ๋อ
เราก็เชิญอร่อยคุณเรียมหวานนิดหน่อยมันก็
จะมีอันนี้นะคุณก็กินอันนี้เนาะสต๊อกนะคะ
เขาก็จะมีช้อนเงินมันจะมีซ้อนไปส่งไว้
เป็นถ้วย
ถ้วยถ้วยช็อคโกแลตมูสแล้วก็จะมีช้อน
เขาก็เล็กไปเนาะ
สอนตัด
แล้วก็กินเองก็ตัดคืออืมอร่อยแล้วก็ตัด
แล้วก็กินแล้วก็เห็นเห็นอะไร
ช็อกโกแลต
ใช่ช็อกโกแลตก็ถูกแค่ช็อกโกแลตมูสใช่ไหม
ไม่มีสตรอเบอร์รี่ไม่มีอะไรท่าน
ผู้หญิงก็เห็นกับตักใส่ในสมุดอ่ะสมมุติ
นักเรียนดูแบบที่ผู้หญิงจากช่วยเพลงก็จาก
คำที่หนึ่งคำที่ 1 โอเคสิ่งก็ตัดคำที่ 2
อะไรทำที่ 2 แล้วก็แบบ
เฮ้ย
เราก็จะมีแบบเขาเรียกเหมือนอย่างเงี้ยเรา
ก็เห็นแบบเอ๊ะอะไร
อันนี้นะ
อะไรเราก็ดูที่ช้อนวันที่ซ้อนอันนี้เราก็
ที่ช้อนนะช้อนตรงนี้นะคะ
เฉลยสอนที่นี่ก็มี
อะไรแล้วมันคืออะไรค่ะผู้หญิง
ดูแล้วก็
แมลงสาป
นักเรียนรู้จักแมลงสาบมั้ยถ้าไม่รู้จัก
วันเกิดให้ดูค่ะเป็นยังไงคะแมลงสาบนี่ค่ะ
แมลงสาบ
คู่เตรียมโอเคไหม
ช่วงข้อกลัวนะแต่ว่าผู้หญิงที่เห็นแบบ
เนี้ยคุณเรียม
ก็คืออันนี้เนี่ยอยู่ในช้อนอ้อมไม่ช้อนนะ
อยู่ในซ้อนส่วนอีกครึ่งนึงตรงนี้
อยู่ในถ้วยคุยชอบ
กินแล้วกินแล้วหนึ่งคำ
รถเท่านั้นแตหญิงรู้สึกยังไงคะรู้สึกยัง
ไงวิ่งจะใช้มากค่ะคุณเรียมคือคุยหญิง
เนี่ยไม่กลัวแมลง 3 นะเห็นอะไร 3 เนี่ย
โอเคไม่ใช่ไม่กลัวทำไมจะแบบตกใจอ่ะอาหาร
มีของกินแมลงสาบและกินได้ไหมคะครูเรียม
กินไม่ได้
กินไม่ได้คนไทยไม่กินคนจีนไม่กินฝรั่งไม่
กินมาแต่แมลงสาปอยู่ในอาหารสินก็แบบตกใจ
แต่คิดทำยังไงอ่ะก็ไม่บอกบอกไม่บอกถ้า
เป็นครูเรียมนะคะครูเรียมเนี่ยกินอาหาร
สมัยที่ร้านอาหารเลยนะแพงใช่ไหมแพงหน้า
สเต็กบวกสลัดก็น่าจะประมาณเป็นบุฟเฟ่ต์นะ
แค่จากประมาณ
ก็นั้นมัน
799 บาทหมู
799 บาทมีสเต็กหนึ่งแล้วก็สลัดสมัยสลัด
อ่ะแต่ว่ารีบถ้าเป็นบุฟเฟ่ใช่ไหมคะแล้ว
ครูเรียมอ่ะเจอเจอแมลงสาบที่นี่ข้างใด
อาหารครูเรียมจะบอก
Staff มั้ยสีไม่เป็นไรไม่เป็นไรเช็คบิน
กลับบ้านบอกค่ะมั้ยบอกค่ะแน่นอน
เรียงทำยังไงอ่ะถ้าสมมติมเจอแมลงสาบใน
อาหารน้อง 5 ความยกมือด้วยใช่ยกเบอร์น้อง
คะแมลงสาบ
แล้วผู้หญิงทำยังไงค่ะ
ผู้หญิงก็บอกค่ะคุณก็แบบตอนแรกคิดบอกไม่
บอกบอกไม่บอกแต่ก็คิดถ้าไม่บอกแล้วคุณ
เรียมมาแล้วเจอก็ไม่โอเคใช่ไหมเพราะว่า
ไม่รู้เพราะมันอยู่ในมูสมันอยู่ใน
ช็อกโกแลตอ่ะเราไม่รู้ว่ามีแมลงสาบแมลง
สาบการรักษาแมลงสาบที่ไหนบ้างชาติเองก็
เลย
โอเคบอกก็เหมือนครูเรียมค่ะยกมือ
ขอโทษนะคะแบบน้องคะพี่คะก็ได้เนาะมีแมลง
สาบเขาก็
ตอนแรกเป็นพนักงานสตาร์ทอัพธรรมดาเพราะก็
แบบก็โอเคค่ะโอเคค่ะเราก็เดินไปแล้วก็ไป
บอก Manager วันนี้ได้เจอก็มาอ้าเราไม่
ได้ขอโทษค่ะ
เขาก็มาขอโทษค่ะขอโทษแล้วถ่ายเขาก็มาขอ
โทษก็ตอนก็เราก็ขอโทษ
ไม่ได้เลี้ยงปลากินไว้ล่ะให้
กูเดียวเจอเจอแมลงสาบในช็อกโกแลตมูสถ้วย
เล็กๆแค่เนี้ยแต่ช็อกโกแลต Wood มันต้อง
เป็นหม้อใหญ่ๆใช่ไหมเราก็จะมีครูหญิงมี
แมลงสาบวันนี้แต่แมลงสาบแมลงสาบแมลงสาบ
ไม่รู้ก็เขาก็ขอโทษค่ะขอโทษค่ะแล้วเขาก็
เดินไปปิ๊งก็อิ่มแล้วเนาะก็เลยเดินไปเช็ค
บิลนะจ่ายเงินนะคะไปจ่ายเงิน
Manager เขาก็บอกว่าโอเคเขาขอโทษวันนี้
ครูหญิงกินฟรีสมัครฟรีไม่ต้องจ่ายเงิน
เขาบอกว่ากินฟรีคุยก็ตอนแรกผู้หญิงคิดเขา
จะลดราคาเหลือสมุดทั้งหมด 799 อาจจะลดให้
20% สมัยรถ
20% อ่ะแต่เขาบอกว่าฟรีนักฟรีเขาขอโทษ
แล้วก็กินฟรีนานไหมคะเจอแมลงสาบอินฟรี
โอเคมั้ยรีบแบบจ่ายเงินโอ้นี่หว่า
ก็ได้เงินดีกว่า
ใช่ไม่มีแมลง 3 ดีกว่าแล้วครูเรียมาคะครู
เรียมเคยไปกินอาหารแล้วก็เจออะไรในอาหาร
ไหมเล่มเคยเจอในแก้วน้ำค่ะ
ผู้เรียนมดอิบน้ำในแก้วน้ำเหรอคะเจ้าน้ำ
แบบไหนคะเจ้าน้ำแบบนี้มองไม่เห็น
แก้วน้ำหรือว่าเป็นใสมองเห็นเห็นได้เอา
เป็นเป็นแก้วนี้ใช่ไหมคะคุณเหลี่ยมใช่ก็
เห็นน้ำแข็ง
เธออะไรอ่ะเธออะไรในแก้วน้ำ
เตรียมกินน้ำเราไม่ใส่น้ำแข็งนะคะ
ไม่ใส่น้ำแข็งก็คือต้องมันจะมีเรียนไม่มี
น้ำแข็งไม่มีน้ำแข็งค่ะมีน้ำเปล่าไม่มี
น้ำแข็ง
จะมีหลอดไฟ
[เพลง]
หลอดไฟอยู่ข้างบนข้างบนครูเรียนไม่ใช่ไหม
คะให้เราแก้วน้ำแข็งเรียนก็ตั้งอยู่แถว
นี้
แก้วนั้น
เป็นคนยกแก้วยกแก้วขึ้นมาดื่มเดี๋ยวคือ
เรียมอันนี้เป็นกลางวันหรือว่ากลางคืนถ้า
มีหลอดไฟและจะกลางคืนไหมใช่ค่ะเป็นตอน
กลางคืน
มาดื่มดื่ม
แล้วก็มองเข้าไปในแก้ว
อะไรเป็นเนี่ยเดี๋ยวครูเรียมคู่เรียนยก
ดื่มๆน้ำเนี่ยหมดไหมหมดหมดแก้วหรือยังอีก
นิดเดียวอีกนิดเดียวทั้งหมด
ใช่เลยไม่เห็นในแก้วคือเวลาดื่มใกล้หมด
ใช่ไหมคะเราก็ต้องยกแก้วสูงขึ้นสูงขึ้น
ใช่มั้ยคะเรียงก็เลยแบบเห็น
คันไหนแกมันเป็นยังไงมันเป็นกลมกลมตัว
ใหญ่ๆเล็กๆหรือว่าใหญ่ๆไม่รู้ขายเล็กๆ
เล็กๆสีอะไรคะที่คุณเรียนเห็นเนี่ยสีดำสี
ดำสีดำสีดำแบบนี้ใช่สีดำแล้วก็มีสีขาว
เรื่องไหนแล้ว
ขอแบบนี้หรอมีสีดำแล้วก็มีสีขาว
ใช่มีสีดำแล้วก็สีขาวแต่มันเล็กๆใช่ไหม
ผู้เดียวค่ะ
แล้วผู้หญิงตอนคุณเรียนอะไหล่
อันนี้หรือเปล่าอ่ะ
แม่
แตงโมใช่ไหมแตงโมอ่ะเราก็มีเม็ดเม็ดแตงโม
ไหมไม่ใช่ไม่ใช่ไม่ใช่เม็ดแตงโม
มันไรคะทุเรียนมาจากอันนี้ค่ะ
จิ้งจกตัวเล็กๆ
บนหลอดไฟหรอใช่ค่ะแล้วมันก็ก็ขี้
ตึ๊ง
ขี้ลงมาในแก้วน้ำ
ต้องใช่
ๆเลี้ยงก็หยิบหยิบขึ้นมาดื่ม
แล้วมันจะมีแบบวุ่นๆเหมือนเจลลี่นิดนึง
เหมือน
ตอนคูเรียมดื่มแล้วเห็นใช่ไหมว่าที่ที่
ก้นของแก้วนะตรงนี้อ่ะค่ะตรงตรงนั้นวัน
เกิดก้นเนาะคนของแก้วเห็นแล้วว่าเป็นขี้
จิ้งจกตอนนั้นน่ะกูเลียมแบบ
ใหญ่จะ
อยากอยากเอาอาทิตย์ฯเข้าไปออก
กลัวอ้วก
[เพลง]
ไม่เล่าเรื่องเราทุเรียนทำยังไงอ่ะทำยัง
ไงแบบเออ
จงในแก้วเดี๋ยวก็ยังอ้ายปะขอแล้วพอแล้ว
ไม่ไม่ดื่มไม่ดื่มน้ำ
มาวันนี้จนถึงวันนี้นะคะเวลาเรียนจะดื่ม
น้ำเลี้ยงก็ต้องดูดูนะแข่วน้ำ
ดวงมีคิดติ้งจกหรือเปล่า
[เพลง]
ให้ดู
2 ผู้หญิงอ่ะนี่อยู่ของครูเรียนน่ะแอบ
ใส่สารนี้คือจิ้งจกนะน้องเวลากันจึงส่ง
อะไรขี้มันเนี่ยมันเป็นก้อนเล็กๆสีดำๆ
แล้วก็เขาขาวๆแต่มันคือขี้อ่ะแล้วมันลงไป
อยู่ในน้ำเป็นยังไงคะน้ำอร่อยไหมก็
ไม่ไม่รู้รสชาติน้ำเปล่า
ชาติเลยแต่ว่าเห็นแล้วเออใช่ตอนแรกดูน้ำ
ก็โอเคดื่มน้ำเพราะเห็นแล้วก็ไม่อร่อยไม่
ให้
เราจะแข็งแรงมั้ยมีขี้จิ้งจกในนะ
น้องก็แค่นี้แหละพี่ไม่โอเคใช่ไหมไม่โอเค
นะเวลานักเรียนน่ะมาประเทศไทยแล้วจะกิน
อาหารในถ้าเป็นแก้วน้ำรู้ก่อนหรือว่า
อาหารก๋วยเตี๋ยวดูแต่อย่างของกูหญิงเนี่ย
ไม่เห็นก็ไม่เห็นตากแล้วคำที่ 1 ก็ไม่
เห็นคำที่สองถึงโอเคว่าแมลงสาบเหมือนด้วย
นั่นแหละแล้วก็คิดว่ารู้ว่า
แก้วกาแฟยามอาทิตย์กินกินไปหมดไม่รู้ไม่
รู้ด้วยแล้วก็ไม่รู้
คุณเรียนว่าโชคดีแล้วเป็นแก้วน้ำมันเป็น
แก้วน้ำมองเห็นใช่ค่ะ
ก็ไม่รู้เนาะนักเรียนเคยเจอแบบครูหญิง
แล้วก็ครูเรียมไหมนาไม่รู้น้องนักเรียนก็
คอมเม้นท์บอกได้บอกด้านล่างได้นะคะแต่ไอ้
ค่ะวันนี้เราก็ไปก่อนเนาะไปสวัสดีค่ะ
สวัสดีค่ะครูผู้หญิง
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนมม.ค